[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité de ce journal ils
sont partout vous piquent pendant votre
sommeil ou même pendant la journée les
moustiques envahissent en cet été nos
espaces verts alors pour y remédier la
métropole de Bordeaux a lancé une
opération démoustification explication
de TV7 la chaîne du groupe sud-ouest à
suivre dans un instant dans ce journal
un instrument étonnant aussi à suivre et
à découvrir dans ce journal La
sinusicale cette lame sonore est de plus
en plus utilisée par les artistes dans
la loi vous allez voir un artisan on a
fait sa spécialité de fabrication TL7
c'est glissé dans son atelier tout à
l'heure enfin elle constitue l'une des
plus belles cavernes d'Europe le gouffre
géant de Cabrespine est un site
exceptionnel la rédaction de via
Occitanie nous racontera son histoire
une vie ré souterraine saisissante vous
le ferez en fin d'édition
ils sont partout et peuvent parfois
gâcher vos soirées d'été les moustiques
adorent la chaleur et l'humidité et si
la plupart des piqûres sont sans danger
pour la santé prenez garde tout de même
aux moustique tigre se nuisible venu
d'Asie il est à 20 ans et désormais
implanté sur une bonne partie du
territoire français à Bordeaux vous
allez le voir le centre de
démystification de la ville et sur le
pied de guerre et scrute
particulièrement les eaux stagnantes un
reportage d'Alix Fourcade et de la
rédaction de TV7 la chaîne du groupe
sud-ouest
dans cette vieille baignoire d'un jardin
de Bacalan se joue une véritable scène
de crime les équipes de Bordeaux
métropole hivertent une bactérie tueuse
de larves de moustiques les granulés
sont enrobés de bacille qui va être
relargué dans la lame d'eau et l'alarme
va en filtre à l'eau va ingérer ses
bacilles qui par un processus va au
niveau du tube digestif entraîné une
occlusion qui entraînera la mort de
l'alarme le centre de des moustication
c'est son nom à pour mission de
débarrasser les jardins de la métropole
bordelaise des moustiques ici c'est
l'association bocale locale qui assure
le suivi des opérations sur le terrain
moi je suis arrivé l'année dernière en
juin et quand je suis arrivé dans les
jardins les jardiniers me disaient qu'il
y avait des moustiques partout et qui
pouvaient pas rester dans les jardins et
voilà donc c'est pour ça que on continue
la sensibilisation cette année une
action d'autant plus importante que la
région a été placée en alerte rouge à
cause de la présence active de
moustiques tigre ces derniers peuvent
être vecteurs des virus de la dengue le
Zika ou encore le chikungunya alors le
centre rappelle quelques conseils
pratiques pour les éviter facilement le
but c'est d'avoir les bons gestes et les
bons gestes s'éveiller à ne pas créer de
collections d'eau artificielles dans son
jardin dans sa cour sur son bolcon donc
pour ça il faut veiller à éliminer à
ranger à mettre à l'abri tous les
réservoirs arrosoir sauts comme ça c'est
propriétaire a encore une autre astuce
mettre des poissons rouges dans ses
récupérateurs d'eau
et je croise les doigts pour qu'il
tienne au moins cinq ans plus de 80% des
gîtes larvaires du moustique commun ou
du moustique tigre se situe dans les
propriétés privées il est donc capital
de vrai chacun à notre petite échelle en
se débarrassant de toutes les eaux
stagnante de nos espaces verts
voilà prudence en ce mois d'août et
éviter donc de laisser de l'eau stagner
dans vos jardins dans vos bassines ou en
espace extérieur
cet été vous profiterez peut-être de
votre temps libre pour faire un peu de
rangement placard cuisine salle de bain
ou encore bureau toutes les pièces de la
maison peuvent être optimisées pour
gagner en bien-être et si vous êtes un
peu perdu à ce propos sachez qu'il
existe des professionnels les home
organiseurs c'est leur nom aménageurs
d'espaces intérieur en français cette
activité est en plein développement chez
nous exemple à Saint-Nazaire vous allez
le voir avec ce sujet le télénante
regardez Delphine on va aller voir ce
cellier pour le découvrir ensemble
alors
c'est une très belle pièce en revanche
c'est vrai que je vois pas mal de
catégories d'objets différentes comme
des chaussettes les outils la nourriture
je pense qu'on peut largement améliorer
tout cela en optimisant le rangement
première étape désencombrer faire du tri
pour laisser la place à un rangement
optimisé Anne-Charlotte et Tom
morganizer aujourd'hui elle est delphine
a réorganisé son cellier mon métier
permet aussi de réutiliser les objets
les meubles les choses des personnes
sans forcément acheter des choses
supplémentaires pour réorganiser de
temps en temps il y a besoin d'acheter
quelques petites boîtes de rangement
mais ça nécessite pas de gros
investissements pour pouvoir améliorer
son organisation
le confinement vécu avec sa famille dans
un 60 mètres carrés à Paris a réveillé
la vocation d'un Charlotte donnée aux
espaces de vie une cohérence une
fluidité dans l'organisation alors mon
credo c'est le bien-être de votre
intérieur est intimement lié à votre
bien-être intérieur je m'explique
lorsqu'on a un espace de vie ou un
bureau un espace de travail rangé on se
sent mieux intérieurement et le
challenge de faire découvrir le métier
aux gens car ils connaissent les femmes
de ménage ils connaissent les
déménageurs mais les hauts-morganiser ça
reste encore très très méconnu
del finale avait entendu parler de ce
métier il y a deux mois elle avait déjà
fait appel à Anne-Charlotte pour l'aider
à aménager sa mezzanine en bureau cette
maman de deux enfants actuellement en
formation avait ce projet depuis
quelques temps mais il lui manquait de
la disponibilité pour se lancer et se
projeter le travail à la maison les
enfants les activités etc c'est vrai que
je ne trouve pas je ne trouve pas ce
temps nécessaire en fait pour voilà pour
m'occuper de la réorganisation en fait
de la maison et donc c'est pour cette
raison si que j'ai fait appel à
Anne-Charlotte elle arrive dans une
pièce et elle a cette capacité en fait à
visualiser ce qui peut être fait voilà
comment ça peut se concrétiser et elle
m'a aidé à trier à trier plus que ce que
je pensais pouvoir le faire elle m'a
fait prendre conscience en fait de tout
ce qu'on a et de et ce qu'on finalement
on n'utilise pas j'aime donner de la vie
aux objets et mettre en valeur les
trésors cachés au fond des placards pour
que ça soit un bonheur visuel pour les
clients côté prix les prestations
Charlotte aussi l'entre 130 et 300 euros
pour une journée complète
ils sont majestueux règnent dans nos
espaces verts et nos jardins pour
certains depuis plusieurs siècles les
arbres remarquables constituent une
richesse essentielle pour la
conservation de la biodiversité de nos
territoires et c'est justement pour
mieux les connaître que la ville de
Limoges s'est lancé dans une opération
de référencement un arbre remarquable se
distingue notamment par sa taille et son
envergure écoutait à ce propos ces
quelques explications microdalindrouot
de la rédaction de 7 à Limoges il a le
temps de grandir et de s'épanouir de
prendre la place qu'il doit prendre
donc c'est ça qui est déjà un caractère
remarquable c'est qu'on leur laisse le
temps de vivre là on est sur des
essences en plus qui poussent
relativement lentement donc leur
la paix effectivement ne pas trop les
tailler ne pas trop intervenir leur
permettre de s'épanouir et quand on va
prendre du recul on va voir qu'il a
vraiment son importance déjà dans ce
jardin là et au-delà si on prenait
encore plus de hauteur on verrait qu'à
l'échelle de la ville il a son pied qui
est complètement important pour la
canopée urbaine protéger les arbres mais
aussi les entretenir pour cela quoi de
mieux que l'usage d'une scie cet outil
historique vous allez le voir ne sert
pas seulement à couper du bois il peut
aussi être employé comme un instrument
de musique et oui la fabrication de la
sinusicale et notamment devenue la
spécialité d'un habitant de la Loire
sujet découverte dans ce département
avec Morgan crawl de TL7 regardez et
écoutez
dans son atelier alexis a STIC une lame
non pas la lame de l'outil pour scier
mais une lame sonore Alexis fauconprez
et facteur d'instruments de musique
depuis 15 ans maintenant il est devenu
le spécialiste de la fabrication de six
musicales
[Musique]
avant tout musicien Alexis vient du
monde des synthétiseurs il aime jouer un
peu partout autour d'un feu de camp par
exemple alors se déplacer avec ce n'est
pas très pratique faites au départ je
voulais créer une version acoustique de
cet instrument qu'on appelle le
thérémine qui est le plus vieux
synthétiseur au monde un synthétiseur
sans clavier qui se joue grâce à une
antenne qui contrôle le volume et une
antenne qui contrôle la hauteur de la
note mais pour pouvoir avoir cette
sonorité là il me fallait un ampli
d'électricité donc en gros j'ai voulu
fabriquer un synthétiseur acoustique de
cette quête du son Alexis s'en fabrique
d'abord un pour son usage personnel cela
nécessite beaucoup de recherches il
étudie le brevet déposé dans les années
30 par un Français et tente de
l'améliorer il crée sa propre version en
respectant au mieux les préconisations
de l'époque la lame a une forme
trapézoïdale ça permet d'avoir deux
formes d'ombre qui se créent quand on
fait vibrer l'instrument et cette forme
non rejoint au centre ce qui fait qu'on
a un son qui est très riche et très
puissant très vite des musiciens
désireux d'acquérir une lame de qualité
frappa sa porte et je me suis rendu
compte qu'il y avait un marché que par
exemple les cirques chercher les 6
musicales depuis de nombreuses années et
que des musiciens
comme des musiciens comme Oliver Ruiz
comme les petites nacelles les orques de
Barback utiliser cet instrument depuis
très longtemps muni d'une crosse à
Calais entre les genoux et d'un poignet
d'inflexion tenu par la main la scie
musicale se joue par le simple
effleurement d'un archer il y a quatre
octaves plus on tient la lame pliée et
tendue vers le bas plus on obtient un
son aigu j'essaye de devoir
le son le plus grave
elles sont plus aigus
[Musique]
l'artisanat Alexis fait réellement du
sur-mesure aujourd'hui il est électrifie
l'instrument acoustique par exemple je
me suis rendu compte il y avait une
grosse demande de la part des musiciens
électroniques donc j'ajoute un jack et
un petit capteur un petit microphone ici
ça permet de brancher l'instrument comme
une guitare électrique directement sur
des effets sur un ampli les lames
d'Alexis sont aujourd'hui jouées partout
dans le monde chaque année se sont entre
40 et 56 musicales qui sont fabriqués
dans son atelier à Riorges
d'instruments donc la base de
documentation c'est des documents
iconographie que ce soit des enluminures
peintures vitraux fresques ça permet
d'avoir beaucoup d'informations plus
certains traités de l'époque après ce
sont des tracés géométriques c'est mon
interprétation avec des règles
du tracé du moyen-âge et c'est ça que
j'aime bien parce que ça offre je dirais
un peu plus de liberté quoi et
d'interprétation personnelle
de la musique à la lecture dans ce grand
JT des territoires nous avons le plaisir
d'être en duplex maintenant avec le
directeur général de Paris Match Patrick
Mahé bonjour Patrick Mahé bonjour à vous
Cyril Viguier Paris Match est encore lu
cet été par de nombreux téléspectateurs
qui nous regardent alors dites-nous
pourquoi Paris Match est-il au fond un
magazine de proximité et des territoires
sur tout
75 ans depuis sa création à 49 et qui
s'est implanté tout de suite dans les
territoires ça ça création même si ça
s'appelle Paris Match suite magazine
match d'avant-guerre et bien c'est la ce
sont les territoires qui lui ont fait sa
grande santé Paris Match a une longue
histoire qui reflète l'histoire de notre
pays aussi Patrick Mahé
franchement effectivement par image qui
va verser 75 printemps qui restent donc
printanier estivale dans l'esprit j'en
provoque il l'a créé disait Paris Match
16 juin de la famille Raymond Castan qui
était le premier rédacteur en chef
disait avec un petit accent de rocaille
pas les matchs c'est le journal qu'on
oublie pas dans les trains ça veut dire
quelque chose et que les gens qui
sillonnaient le pays pouvaient acheter
une foutue de journaux et elle avait un
ils apportaient chez eux c'était par
image et c'est la raison pour laquelle
on voit aujourd'hui que dans des
familles des gens ont des collections
entières du journal qu'ils ont
hérité de leur grand-parents ou de leurs
parents il y a une transmission à
travers
Patrick m'a est en quoi Paris Match
reste-t-il moderne malgré le temps qui
passe
dès qu'un événement se passe dans un
territoire et pas les marins-pêcheurs
par exemple la grande sécheresse les
sécheresses qu'on annonce de la canicule
Paris Match là Paris Match est là pour
raconter des histoires des histoires
humaines des histoires que qui sont
souvent évoquées et qui passent trop
vite ailleurs et que nous au contraire
nous perpétue
merci Patrick Marie d'avoir été l'invité
du Grand JT des territoires très bel été
à vous et à toutes ces rédaction de
Paris Match à très vite dans ce journal
à 90 ans il est l'un des dernières
rescapés de la rafle du Vél' d'Hiv de
juillet 1942 après le cinéma et un livre
Joseph Weissman raconte désormais son
histoire dans une BD elle est intitulée
après la rafle celle-ci décrit notamment
son évasion d'un camp d'internement avec
un ami une histoire bouleversante vous
allez le voir dans la Sarthe laurgira a
assisté à une rencontre de l'auteur avec
le public un reportage émouvant pour
elle mT Les Sartre
dans la bande dessinée comme dans le
livre qu'il a précédé Joseph Weisman
commence le récit de son histoire par
son évasion avec son copain Joe celle du
camp de baume-la-rolande dans le Loiret
lieu de transit avant déportation des
juifs pendant la guerre le symbole est
clair grâce à cet acte Joseph choisit la
vie car le surlendemain je ressens doute
été déporté et aujourd'hui mais centre
blanchirait sur les cendres qui sont
Auschwitz le 7 mai 2022 une rencontre
est organisée dans une librairie du Mans
comme à chaque fois la salle et comble
est pleine d'enfants qui pose de
nombreuses questions notamment celle-ci
mais pourquoi avez-vous jeté votre
casquette alors que vous avez réussi à
traverser plusieurs mètres de barbelés
de l'autre côté j'étais tellement
soulagé c'était une manière d'exprimer à
la fois en soulagement et la réussite
quand je témoigne je suis un enfant
lorsque je leur dis d'ailleurs souvent à
mes élèves vous ne voyez pas devant vous
le grand-père que je suis mais chez
l'enfant de 11 ans qui va vous raconter
ce qui s'est passé et je leur parle et
parce que
ça aurait pu être et d'ailleurs beaucoup
se sont immergés et les parents en
disant je vois ma fille de 11 ans je
vois mon fils de 11 ans et donc il faut
savoir que les enfants ne sont pas à
l'abri non plus dans les guerres qu'on
fait aujourd'hui on fait la guerre aux
enfants ce qui n'existait pas avant vous
voyez ce qu'on peut faire des enfants ça
n'a jamais dû exister il aurait dû avoir
des révoltes ça n'a pas été fait si un
jour vous trouvez dans cette situation
ne l'acceptez pas depuis sa rencontre
avec Simone Weil lors d'un colloque en
1996 Joseph Iceman n'a de cesse de
témoigner de l'horreur du régime nazi
sans haine mais avec une grande lucidité
je crois que c'est surtout une grande
leçon d'humanité que Monsieur Weissman
donne à l'Assemblée donc toute tranche
confondue toute tranche d'âge confondu
l'espoir né de l'action née du refus de
la fatalité un message toujours actuel
si par exemple dans le monde entier tout
le monde se soulevait il y avait tous
les jours des millions de gens qui
manifestent contre Poutine contre la
guerre contre sa ferait peut-être
quelque chose mais on fait pas assez un
témoignage qui nous oblige après la
rafle était un roman un film et
dorénavant une bande dessinée adaptée au
plus jeune
voilà un beau message délivré une idée
de lecture en ce mois d'août ou pour la
rentrée aussi
une idée envoie la une autre une
exposition consacrée à Goldorak rien à
voir le fameux dessin animé japonais qui
a marqué vous le savez toute une
génération d'enfants et puis bonne
nouvelle pour les adultes désormais le
robot juste ici de l'espace et sur terre
pour une exposition donc à Amiens un
rendez-vous forcément gigantesque qui
nous replonge dans le plaisir plus de 40
ans en arrière sujet de Jérémie Houbron
pour oui au TV la chaîne du groupe La
Voix du Nord
très loin dans l'espace derrière cette
bande originale bien connue toute une
génération retombe en enfance le temps
d'une exposition acte et son
emblématique robot reprennent du service
à la Maison de la Culture d'Amiens s'il
retrouve les fidèles du prince de force
ceux qui ont suivi ses aventures à
l'antenne en 78 et tous ceux qui ont
déjà au moins une fois entendu le nom de
Goldorak c'était un rendez-vous qui
était vraiment
incontournable on a les DVD on a des
figur toute mon enfance c'est une
idole c'est ma mère qui m'en parlait en
fait génération X 31 Albator Goldorak et
donc en fait plus curieux de découvrir
pour la première fois ce matériel 40 ans
après la parution du dernier tome de la
série un collectif d'auteur offre une
suite à cette icône de la pop culture
parmi eux un spécialiste de la
science-fiction Denis Bajram en
reprenant tous les codes du manga ces
thèmes récurrents tels que la lutte du
bien contre le mal il dépoussière le
héros nippon notre nostalgie nous
souvenir d'enfance incroyable parce
qu'en fait ce qu'on a vu qu'on est gamin
c'est toujours énorme on essaie de le
refaire avec les moyens d'aujourd'hui
nos moyens déjà d'auteur mais même enfin
tout ce qu'on a appris au delà des
fascicules figurines et autres produits
dérivés l'opportunité se présente aux
visiteurs de découvrir la genèse de ce
Goldorak à la française
c'est assez ludique comme exposition
parce qu'en fait vous allez voir les
étapes de création de la bande dessinée
en fait en partant du scénario et en
suivant sur le storyboard et sur les
pages couleur finalisées en fait c'est
vraiment très intéressant parce que ben
voilà ça permet de découvrir aussi le
métier de créateur de BD l'exposition de
Goldorak à Goldorak du ras jusqu'en
octobre ce qui laisse le temps aux
nostalgique et au néophyte de venir
prendre non pas un coup de vieux mais
peut-être un fulguir au point
[Musique]
voilà partons désormais à la découverte
des richesses naturelles de nos régions
en Occitanie les gouffres géants de
Cabrespine font partie des plus belles
cavernes d'Europe leur histoire remonte
à l'âge de bronze et leur immensité ne
laisse personne insensible une plongée
souterraine saisissante avec Anne-sophie
Pellegrini de la rédaction de vie à
Occitanie regardez
donc voilà on approche la l'entrée
naturelle d'ailleurs on sent le
l'Afrique qui sort des profondeurs il y
a 54 ans deux adolescents membres du
spelet au club de l'Aude Gérard Bratt et
Jean Giraud se dirigent vers la grotte
le gars depuis plusieurs années les
spéléologues pressante que le réseau
cache un trésor et les explorations vont
bons trains et ce sont les deux amis
âgés d'une quinzaine d'années qui
découvrirent le gouffre de Cabrespine
ces deux jeunes explorateurs à l'époque
ils étaient résister à dos ont vu une
chauve-souris qui partait par une
crevasse ils se sont perçu un courant
d'air comme aujourd'hui on sent l'air
frais qui sort ils ont commencé à
élargir cette fissure ils sont tombés
sur un petit boyau une galerie étroite
de 100 mètres cette entrée naturelle est
aujourd'hui protégée par le réseau
Natura 2000 car abritant une vaste
colonie de chauve-souris ouverte au
public en 1988 en entre dans le gouffre
par une seconde entrée un gouffre que
l'on voit tel que l'on vu les premiers
explorateurs aménagés sur de hauteur et
avec une passerelle de verre qui s'étage
sur 4 niveaux là on est face à face à
une grande paroi stalagmitique alors
c'est en demi devine une ancienne
arrivée d'eau face à nous puisque il
faut savoir que le gouffre a été creusé
par une rivière souterraine il y a de
cela plusieurs millions d'années donc
une fois que le vide s'est créé des
arrivées d'eau annexes se sont produites
et cette calcification passe de nous qui
a plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'années qui est très très anciennes
pour une ancienne arrivée d'eau un peu
deviner une ancienne cascade qui devait
couler là il y a quelques millénaires en
arrière il fallut attendre 20 ans au
premier explorateurs pour contempler
l'ampleur de ses beautés
ici ils avaient à l'époque de simples
l'an passé thylaine donc c'était vous
savez ces petites flamme sur le casque
et quand ils sont arrivés dans cette
immense salle il percevait l'immensité
des lieux par rapport à la résonance des
voix par rapport à les cours mais ils
avaient du mal à apercevoir le plafond
quand même s'ils étaient au fond chaque
étage à ces trésors chaque concrétion un
nom cierge fistulence de calcite lustre
et chou-fleur non c'est la ragonite vue
de très près
[Musique]
de plus précieux et de plus rares dans
le milieu souterrain c'est le Graal des
spéléo et ça fait penser un petit peu à
du corail ou à des parois qui ont été
givrées avec des cristaux de glace et
puis on trouve notre type de roche moins
acérées plus ronde moulée et transportée
ici par la main de l'homme à l'intérieur
la cuve et l'enfant qui repose dans des
conditions optimales soit une
température constante de 14 degrés et un
taux d'humidité de 90% minimum
dans ces conditions de température
constante et on va agir vraiment sur la
structure du vin par une
micro-oxygénation ça va apporter plus de
finesse et plus de
plus de douceur faire évoluer les arômes
plus rapidement le gouffre de Cabrespine
accueille près de 80 000 visiteurs par
an et fait partie d'une des plus belles
cavernes
[Musique]
direction la Martinique pour terminer
cette édition avec d'autres images
éblouissantes celle d'un volcan
totalement décapité par l'érosion à
Sainte-Anne la savane des pétrifications
c'est son nom offre un paysage quasi
lunaire aussi incroyable que
spectaculaire Jean-Marc d'Abreu et Teddy
Albert de la rédaction de via ATV en
Martinique nous y conduisent pour une
escapade volcanique regardez
au sud de la Martinique
bordée par la mer des Caraïbes une
plaine aux faux aires de désert la
savane de pétrification ou la promesse
d'un dépaysement garantie au beau milieu
de cet espace inattendu nous croisons ce
groupe de randonneurs habitué des lieux
quand je viens ici en fait c'est parce
que j'ai l'impression de ne pas être en
Martinique en fait quand j'ai besoin de
sortir un peu dans mon île sans partir
visiter la savane de pétrification c'est
aussi faire une balade dans le temps il
y a 23 millions d'années l'île aux
fleurs est née ici il reste encore des
traces de cette époque lointaine ouais
là je viens de
ramasser un morceau de bois pétrifié
pétrifié ma réalité c'est du bois
silicier pourquoi parce que il y a plus
de bon à l'intérieur en fait le bois il
est fibreux un bout de bois pourri et ce
bois a été traversé par des remontées
hydrothénomales c'est-à-dire de l'eau
riche en silice dont on retrouve au
coeur d'un volcan totalement décapité
nous sommes en train de réaliser là le
rêve un peu fou de Jules Verne
c'est-à-dire pour rentrer au cœur de
volcan de ce passé volcanique découle en
sollargileux et très fertile une terre
idéale pour la culture du melon cette
exploitation d'une centaine d'hectares y
étaient planté depuis une quinzaine
d'années les plaques sont puissantes et
nous donne un produit une grande qualité
donc le fait d'être à proximité du de
cette zone
nous nous fait partager la d'un terroir
exceptionnel une nature généreuse et
captivante ce photographe professionnel
on a fait son terrain de chasse favor il
y a beaucoup de d'espaces différents là
on parlait du païencieux mais on vient
de voir le balbuzzarepaisseur pêcheur
passé il y a la frégate le pélican on a
l'impression d'être sur l'eau avec les
oiseaux jadis pour le plus haut de l'île
la savane de pétrification offre
aujourd'hui à un panorama unique sur la
Martinique
voilà c'est la fin de ce grand JT des
territoires merci de nous avoir suivi
dans cette édition de l'été on se
retrouve très vite pour une nouvelle
édition au revoir à tous
[Musique]